none on neuroplasticity and neuro
degeneration and so I want to do you
have brain initiative going on
you have the connectome going on and so
this is mapping all of the neural
pathways and neural networks within our
entire nervous system right this is very
exciting
teach us about why this is so important
so the brain is is very special in many
ways it's one of the things that
separates us from other animals our
ability to to think about the past the
future - you know it's not just memory
it's our ability to to think out of the
box to intuit to emot-- to show sympathy
and all of that's we could another thing
makes it unique is you can replace
almost any part of your body I mean as
we go into the future
organ transplants will become very easy
but it's hard to play certain parts of
your brain that are responsible for the
memories that make you you so we want to
learn more about how that's encoded and
we want to do it inexpensively something
that could be used clinically where we
know the connection of every you know
every Dhin neuron might be connected to
a thousand other neurons you know thirty
six billion neurons each of the thousand
connections are big range and and
whether those connections are inhibitory
or excitatory we can map out this at
molec single molecule level so we can
really go down to a resolution of the
synapse and we and we have a big
government project from my our pub
called the microns project that it aims
for synapse oil revolution resolution
connectome plus we can find out what the
lineage of those cells were you know
what cells begat you know what
precursors would behave we became those
cells where they migrated and what and
what they're expressed in status which
again is relevant to understanding and
if you had to that kind of deep
understanding you could reconstruct it
if it got broken yeah potentially
and we're going to start with very
simple things like dopamine and
Parkinson's but eventually we'll get to
more be able to reconstruct more and
more complicated connectomes